大家好,我是Yoni,欢迎今天来参加咱们这场分享会所有的小伙伴们,那也非常感谢今天来为咱们分享的嘉宾哈,是咱们天晴量化官方核心团队成员,也是我的好朋友李思恒老师,那思恒老师呢是深耕量化很多年了,同时呢也是持有CFA和FRM金融双证哈,那作为我们天晴量化的技术总监呢是兼顾着天晴量化产品线的迭代与策略的开发应用,那继上次思恒老师给咱们分享量化入门之后呢,其实我跟思恒老师也一直在聊,
就目前AI在量化领域的运动
以及如何能够让AI
对于像我们一些刚入门量化
想借助AI降低学习门槛的新手
或者是像我们深耕行业很多年
希望用AI来提升策略开发效率的从业者
又或者是如何能够让咱们天行量化平台的
诸多功能来为我们解决实际应用当中会遇到的问题
那接下来呢
我就把时间交给思恒老师
让为大家带来我们干货满满的分享
好吧
那思恒老师时间交给你了
好的谢谢Yoni老师的介绍
就是这次也是记上一次的那个直播以后
然后我们开的第二节课
我也得想到底讲什么
就是上一次是大概介绍了天气量化
以及就是量化这个领域
然后一些事情嘛
然后我在想
就是我们的分享会
比如说就一小时
只是讲软件功能或者什么
其实我跟Uni老师聊了一下
感觉并不适合
原因是软件功能这些东西
大家去看说明书什么都可以
没有必要大家聚在一起
然后就讲这种比较枯燥的东西
那我觉得更多的可能是经验分享这一类的
可能大家比较喜欢听
也是更有帮助一些
那最近呢
本来AI就比较的火
然后加上上个月的时候
去北京那边开了两场
关于AI的会议
进行一个讲说
大家反响也挺不错的
所以说我就跟Yoni老师说
这一次继续
我们的主题就是讲AI这一块
AI这一块这节课
主要分享几个大块
跟大家说一下
我不会教大家
到底怎么具体去用AI
或者怎么样
这在最后分享的时候
会说一下
我主要是接触了很多人
就是包括天庭的大群
小群很多客户来找我
都把AI想的有一些
认知的偏差有点严重
那我觉得这个分享课的
第一个重心
大家正确的来理解一下AI
和我们来聊一下
到底AI是不是能帮我们忙
这也是抛一个这个影子在这边
大家可以想一下
AI是不是真的能帮我们忙
那么神奇
第二呢是
我觉得AI这个东西
现在很多外面的虚假信息太多了
包括教大家就是
AI就是能帮助你这样那样
今天刚听一个同事
跟我聊了一个故事
他家里人
然后要报这个AI的课
想去学像佑尼老师这样的up主
觉得做短视频啊
什么用AI就能猛猛赚钱
然后问他为什么呢
也不清楚
但就觉得AI很厉害
应该多能赚钱
其实这一类的误区
放到咱们身上做量化的
其实也是一定程度上有的
特别写代码之类的
我们很多客户
可能自己Python还不会写
然后天晴也是刚看
但是我去问他的时候
他就很自信跟我说
说厉老师没问题
我有AI
我有DeepThink
等等等等
我学习完全不是问题
其实他确实能帮我们
提高一个效率
但是他解决不了的问题
在哪里
解决不了的问题是
我们去效率的路上
那个基数是多少
因为0乘以1000也是0
因此这次我想跟大家聊的是
把大家那个0
起码的变成个0.2 0.3
对吧
那你成个100
也是有点希望的
也能提高效率
这是我这节课的一个初衷
想跟大家聊的是这东西
所以说这节课呢
我们也不用特别的
这个紧张或什么
大家就一个聊天的这种心态
大家一起聊一下
一起来讨论一下
到底AI到底怎么帮助我们
做量化交易
以及最后呢
会分享一下
我现在用的AI有什么
以及我到底在怎么用这个AI
还有我自己遇到的问题和误区
我怎么快速把它纠正的
希望对大家有些帮助
好吧
开始的时候呢
我们还是比较
按部就班的
介绍一下我们公司
因为今天下午的时候
在跟几个客户聊天的时候
他跟我说
你们公司不就快期吗
我说对
其实我们母公司
叫信义信息科技
只不过我们那个产品
快期二快期三
它有名了
所以把母公司的名
给盖过去了
其实我们公司呢
有快期二快期三
还有这个天晴
APP
产业都有
都有
只要是跟期货有关的
我们公司基本上
全部都能覆盖
定制化项目也做
所以我们母公司
大家下次可以记一下
叫信义信息科技
有限公司
我们的母公司
不是上汽技术
好多人认为我们是上汽技术
我们只是跟上汽所的关系
比较好一点
并不是上汽所的子单位
好 我们直接进入话题
不多废话
第一个我们来想一想
这个点叫做AI能帮我们什么
这个东西其实非常大的一个命题
就是大家也可以想想
你们用AI的一个初衷是什么
我接触到很多天气良化的客户
用AI想跟我讲的是
代替他学习
就是他希望AI能帮助他
把Python学会
把天性学会
以及别的东西
像是我跟悠悠老师
最近也在请教的
像是这种
比如说因子分析
大家也都觉得比较新颖的一些词
觉得能挣钱的一些词
大家都希望我
什么都不会的情况下
AI帮我学会这些东西
可不可能呢
我个人的答案是不太可能
因为我觉得
AI做不到这一点的原因很简单
就是当我跟你说一个事情
一个陈述句的时候
你不知道我在说什么
你是判断不了
我跟你讲的对错的
AI是一个道理
你在问他的时候
他会跟你讲得非常的好
会给你解释得非常的通顺
但是当你不能理解
他讲的语言是什么样的时候
他仅仅是一些字
拼凑在一起
这也是AI的一个底层
AI的底层就是语言工具
它确确实实做了一个活
就是把文字拼凑到一起
也就是说你给它一个问题以后
它做的逻辑并不是说它帮你思考
而是认为在它的数据库里
最大概率给你的第一个字是什么
第二个字是什么
以此类推
这是AI做的事
因此AI它并不能理解我们的思想
它是如何做到理解我们思想的
我后面会给大家去讲述
它是怎么实现的
以及我们在这边能怎么优化
那么AI能帮我们什么
我个人的一个总结是这样的
我认为只有两点
这是我个人的一个解释
不是标答
就是这节课
我再强调一下
没有标答
每个人心中
都有自己一个答案
我只是分享一下
我自己的一个想法
首先它作为搜索引擎
我认为是比较成功的
也有数据支持
上个月看的论文
在写这篇PPT的时候
看的一个论文
有一个调查报告
AI现在已经代替
传统的网页搜索
代替的比较的成功了
然后网页端的搜索用户
也下降的比较厉害
特别是医疗板块
那个识别文字嘛
我直接发给DP-Seq
我说你看我这个症严不严重
我这个病怎么样
他会给我复述的还不错
因为医生毕竟去挂科
他只是给你讲一些非常简单的
你也不能理解
然后你多问两句呢
我有点害怕
我就拿着体检包包
最后就问一下
AI效果还不错
然后呢
AI还有个好处是
他去推掉了大部分的广告
比如说今天我在会议之前
我发现我这个电脑
还没有装腾讯会议
我就去百度
我发现第一条第二条
竟然不幸不是腾讯会议的官网
我要往下搜
AI呢
它就会适时的帮你筛选掉
一定的广告和推广
包括大家以前都是
比较流行的叫SEO
SEO是什么意思
就是搜索引擎的优化
怎么能把你要的东西
在搜索引擎里面推广上去
AI现在呢
属于比较新的一个工具
因此它的SEO
做的还没有特别成熟
大家对它算法解析
还不是那么成熟
因此想在AI上面做广告
你看到广告的频率
相对于网页来说
是较低的
所以它作为搜索功能
是不错的
你如果想搜过什么东西
你把它那个联网打开
还是能帮你节省一定时间的
但是我有一个建议
在这里是什么呢
当你看到的建议以后
当你看到结果以后
我建议你把那个
它联想的网页
会你标注一个数字
打开
稍微看一下
这个是我跟我同事
有聊过一个问题
我个人的一个习惯
还是在AI给我任何答案之后
我会求证一下
我比较相信原始的网页
可能我的思想
还没有那么先进
那很多人的做法
是直接AI给了一个信息
你就本能地接受了
你认为它是不会出错的
但是我觉得这比较危险的一个想法
所以说我还是建议大家
在拿到搜索的答案以后呢
点开每个网页进去看看
看他的答案是怎么来的
以及现在DeepSeek
做的这种模型
他是有一个深度思考
你看他思考过程
再去看一下
他到底思考的对不对
多方求证以后
你再去相信他的答案
或者不相信他的答案
这是我个人的一个建议
第二代写工具是不错的
代写工具这一点
我下午的时候
跟Uni老师那聊天
我就说想学一下
关于比如说这个
因子挖掘
比如说这个叫机器学习
这一块
Uni老师这一块非常的厉害
大家对这一块
就是技术感兴趣
可以完全可以联系Uni老师
我也在那边学习
那么环境配置这一块
虽然我写天心写那么久了
我还是比较容易能
用Python安装出来的
但是我在思考
我说假如我不会怎么办
那么下午我就跟AI在那边
聊了很久
大概也不是很久
半小时左右
他们问题都给我解决了
然后我把库装好以后
我就在想
那我怎么证明我的库装好了
我让他给我写了四个demo
四个例子
大概花了十分钟就写完了
一共的代码量
我数了一下应该是三千多行
两三千行
两三千行十分钟
是一个什么概念呢
就是你让我打两三千行字
我十分钟都不一定能写得出来
这就是效率的提升
这也是我讲的
你的基数
后面的那个乘数
是AI是绝对能帮助你的
你的效率会大幅度的提升
它能短时间内
输出大量的文字代码
是没有问题的
它的数据库
也能帮你分析问题
也没有问题
但是你前面的基数
一定不是零
就是你一定要懂
懂是什么意思
我等一下尽量找一下
我觉得他出错的地方
给大家解释一下
在最后实操了
他就能更深的领悟这一点了
就是他输出了一大堆的字
在你能理解之前
他都是废话和
没有意义的一堆字节
比如他给你了一千行代码
你如果这一千行代码
不知道怎么去辨别
或者不知道怎么去认证
这是你要的东西
那这一千行代码
只是浪费你的时间而已
对吧
因此在写东西的时候
代码和文字
你自己要有自己的思路
我们公司现在很多文案
用这个AI写的
写的确实还蛮不错的
但是呢我个人是一个
比较喜欢手写东西的人
我觉得书写的过程
是一种思考的过程
写代码也是一样
大家不要去学的写代码
是个很枯燥的东西
写代码其实跟写文章来说
我觉得是一样的
都是一个
对于你逻辑的一种认证
其实呢就是
你去思考这一篇文章
从头到尾该怎么写
和你去写一个策略
从头到尾怎么写
是一样的
你能想的越具体
你能把上下文串的越好
写的东西越好
当你串不起来的时候
AI是不能帮你什么的
因为它给你提供的这些创意和灵感
只是一些冰冷的文字
就是我们有时候说叫没有灵魂
大家可以想想这个问题
因此总结就是
我觉得AI如果你有一定的能力
你把它当做搜索和帮你代写
一部分代码量
一部分文字的时候
我非常建议你用
完全没有问题
这是第一个话题
我们来看第二个话题
第二个话题
我们和一些客户聊过了
这个问题可能大家就觉得比较蠢
说电脑怎么会有思维呢
这也是引申我第一次
就是在最开始讲的
AI我认为是一个语言工具
所以这边我也提前剧透了一个结论
我认为AI是没有思维的
没有思维
这是我个人的一个结论
大家不要去觉得这个是对或者错
大家可以自己想一想
为什么我会这么说
我给大家解释一下
我觉得AI的思维
是我们不能理解的
最开始的时候
在一两年前
当时GPT非常火
我们公司其实也比较走在前面
从AI开始的时候
我们公司就采购
使用试用
然后来琢磨
能不能帮我们公司提高效率
也是借着这种呢
我也是很早就体验了GPT
GPT在一开始时候非常的厉害
他去回答一些问题
你感觉跟活生活现在人一样的
但是
大家可能看过图
我不知道有没有看过
但是GPT它不能解决
十亿内的加减法
它不能解决
但是其他的大问题
它都可以解决
为什么会有这种情况呢
因为他不太能理解
加是什么
减是什么
他不太能理解
一些逻辑上
我们指的好或者不好是什么
又或者我们讲的赚钱
他可能知道是钱增加
但是他很难理解
一个好的策略
是什么意思
因此他能理解一部分
我们的一些叙述
他可以理解
你给我一个赚钱的东西
到底赚不赚钱
到底是不是亏钱
回撤大不大
收益率高不高
他在网上能找一些
和一些数据库
底层能找一些
大部分的大数据
来给你对比
你的五回撤怎么样
你的十收益率怎么样
他可以给你说
但是你问他好或者不好
或者是之类的
又或者你跟他讲
像我们客户特别
在一开始AI的时候
我们有个AI助手吗
我在后台能看到一些问题
因为我要去纠错
大部分人问的问题就是
给我一个赚钱的策略
这个大家可能觉得这样问很离谱
但是我可以给大家说
这是我每天看后台数据里面
最高频的一个问题
就是给我一个赚钱的策略
它离谱在哪里呢
就是因为AI无法去理解
你要一个赚钱的策略
是个什么样的策略
对吧
它不能理解这件事
它也不知道现在什么策略赚钱
第二呢是
我们去问它这个问题的时候
如果AI能给你答案
我们假如说科技飞升
科技进步
你去问AI
给你一个赚钱的策略
它就能给你一个赚钱的策略
或者你去问它
我们在Twitter休息室
给我一个双均线
可靠的策略
它就可以给你一个双均线
那么我们这节课也可以不用上
我们期货交易者
应该这个职业也应该没了
原因就是因为没有任何门槛了
没有门槛的职业
是没有盈利点的
对吧
所以说AI它的思维
跟我们的思维是不太一样的
它其实就是在算一个概率
怎么回答我们
它也是计算机底层的一种计算机语言
并不是我们人类的语言
因此AI的逻辑是怎么来的呢
它的逻辑其实是
我们把问题拆分的够细
比如说给我一个赚钱的策略
我们来拆它
我可以带大家拆一下
如果说我来去拆这东西
我也是现想
不是提前准备的备稿
我一般讲的时候都是想到什么
跟大家分享什么
大家可以想想
如果你要问AI
给我一个赚钱的策略
你会怎么拆这个问题
如果我来拆的话
首先赚钱的策略
那不用说了
你最后的表现一定要是
回撤收益比要大于1对吧
那没有回撤收益比大于1
我觉得比较赚钱
甚至你要是1.5
或者说你下谱
你的所听的比率要多少等等等等
我会给他一个清晰的标准
这就他可以理解了
什么叫挣钱
比如说下谱比率是多少
为民的这个盈利率要多少
我的回撤最大是多少
或者说我去算我的这个盈亏的一个叫做
方差标准差
就是我的波动率是多大
对吧
我就定义了结果
那么开始我怎么定义呢
赚钱的策略起码是策略对吧
那我就会跟他说
我要个双均线策略
双均线策略
他也不能理解
什么叫双均线呢
我会再给他细化
我说你先帮我写两条均线
一个是15
一个是20
或者说一个是A
一个是B
他们的周期是A和B
这是为什么呢
是我后面可能我
就会自然而然想到
我在最后的一步的时候
让他帮我去调餐
把A和B从0到50
随机选取数字
不停地跑回测
看哪个数字最好
那这样大家可以看到
一个很模糊
很抽象的一句话
帮我赚钱的策略
就能具体了
他就可以帮我去实施了
而且我问他每个问题
我是有后文的
这种逻辑是只有我们人
去串他的
去把它串起来
去告诉他的
而不是你指望他来给你
是不可能的
所以说大家在用AI之前
其实或者说用天晴之前
或者用写量化之前
我觉得所有人的这个问题
都不是代码
这是我一直以来观念
我觉得大家都不是亏欠在代码上
不是亏欠在技术上
而是没有想好
你赚钱的逻辑到底是什么
所以大家没事的时候
可以自己在那思考
或者自己跟自己抬杠
我很喜欢跟自己抬杠
我这个赚钱的思路
到底是合不合理
到底有没有这个稳定性
当你能跟自己去和解
把这个稳定性和逻辑
想好的时候
你用AI也好
你用手工交易也好
用量化交易也好
你是什么因子挂角
技术大拿等等等等
都无所谓
这是我想表达的一个点
就是AI的思维是没有的
但人类的思维是不可代替的
这是绝对不可代替的
那么第二个
就引申出来这个问题
大家就很好理解了
为什么我觉得AI说的对的
其实这是一个主观偏差的问题
主观一个意向偏差的问题
很多时候我们不是觉得
AI给的答案对
可能我们自己也不知道答案是什么
但是我们觉得它讲的挺有道理的
因为它很会编
它非常的会编
所以说我们觉得它是对的
第二就是我们主观是有滤镜的
觉得AI很高科技很先进
每个时代都有自己的一个
AI这种很先进的东西
像上个时代
我们也有些先进的技术
我们也不知道它是对是错
但我们就觉得真的好高级
它就是对的
你现在就回头去看
有很多这样的例子在这边
你也会觉得啊
那时候这个东西好蠢啊
对吧
都是有这种例子在
所以AI只是新时代的一个
新玩意儿罢了
对吧
然后呢
因为这东西呢
它新嘛
新就在风口上
我们经常说在风口上
一头猪洞的吹起来
因此呢
也有大量的营销号
大量的就是起号
去做这个AI相关的东西的
去卖AI相关的课的
因此把AI吹的
就会神乎其神
大家在接触
大量这种信息以后呢
就会默认觉得
AI确实蛮厉害的
因此呢
AI会你会觉得很对
很多时候不是你的问题
是整体的一个氛围
把它轰突到这里了
所以说我们一定要想明白
一定要有判断的能力
你就能超出大部分人了
下一个问题呢
就是AI它既然是这么一个东西
那我们要干什么
刚刚我讲了一部分
就是逻辑上我们是主人
AI只是我们的一个
普通
帮我们来写东西
把逻辑给实现
仅此而已
所以说拆解问题是核心
就是像我刚刚给大家举的例子
就是拆解问题
我们把一个赚钱策略
给它拆解下来
怎么让它写一个赚钱策略
这就叫拆解问题
所以说呢
我们最大的差异化
就是你拆解问题的能力
现在有很多付费的AI
大家都会觉得很贵
我们之前也去看了很多
AI都觉得很贵
贵是我没钱啊
不是他不好
他是做了一个什么事呢
比如说我们刚刚说的那个
给我一个赚钱的策略这件事
他会把这个问题拆得很细
来帮我做这件事
我就不用去思考了
同时他把这个拆解的问题
再交给AI的底层
比如说DeepSig R1
比如说Cloud
现在是3或者4了
这些底层或者GPT的O3
这才是真正的AI的在思考的东西
它呢是帮你来把它拆分完
交给它
让它来思考
那么你就会觉得
这个过程就顺多了
我要做的事也少多了
你需要思考的也少多了
这就是很多
现在AI的一些这个软件啊
或者东西
它卖你卖的是什么
你们要知道
它卖的是代替你思考过程
它卖的并不是底层
底层就在那
你可以直接用
你可以直接买
但是有可能你拆分问题
没有它拆分的好
或者说你没有它
研究出来这套模板
来拆分问题
那你给它付费
付的是这个东西
这是第一个
第二呢
就是严格的固定的工作流
也是接着我刚刚说的
如果你能做出一个
严格的固定的工作流
这也是我非常推荐大家的
我也在做这个工作
我也在学习这个东西
那么你的AI工作效率
会大大提升
第三呢
就给他一些情形下的
该处理的办法
我给大家分享一个
我上个月写的东西
真实遇到的情况
我上个月要写一个什么呢
我上个月要写一个
自动的脚本
这个脚本要做到两件事
第一是我用AI
比如说豆包
比如DeepSeek
去生成一些文案
第二呢
我要把这些文案发到各种论坛上去
其实说白了就是叫水军
大家都听过这个词
就是我要做一个自动化水军
好
那自动化水军有个什么问题
就是我不可能直接让他告诉我
怎么做一个自动化水军
因此我把问题拆分成了三步
大家也可以想想
如果你要做一个自动化水军
你会怎么拆分
让AI帮你写
首先我全程是没有自己写任何东西的
第二是我没有写一行代码
都让他来写的
但是问题是我自己在拆分
首先我要拆分的是三个点
你把一个事情拿到
你要把它拆到三个大的步骤
写策略是一样的
你一定要这么拆
我觉得三个步骤
第一就是我要解决
跟豆包跟DBC一个交流
提问这一步
第二呢
我要解决的是
把这个问题给录入
合理的录入
第三步呢
我要去论坛
去发水的水军的帖子
就拆掉这三步了
那么呢
我就这么一步一步往下拆
其实拆了就会更细
等会给大家分享一下
我是怎么拆的
那我每一步都做的没有问题
但是我发现一个大问题
就是我把它合并起来的时候
我运行不了了
这问题我就结了快半天
最后我发现原因是什么
是他在把三个正确代码合并的时候
他把中间的代码改了
改成不可用了
这就是一个非常大的问题
AI他会告诉你
我没有改
我问了他
我说你改了没
他说我不会改
但他还是改了
因为你用AI的时候
可以对比这个代码
能看得出来
因此呢
我跟他实在拧不过他
因为上下文
其实是只有
比如说50个问答
可能上下文太多了
他没有办法处理
我让他做什么呢
我让他们每一个单独部分
我不说三部分吗
单独去存一份Python文件
叫Beta
单独存了三份
然后我另起了一个对话
跟他说这是三个文件
你来把它们合到一起
那这样的时候
他就处理好了
并且我跟他说
你要再单独合成一个Python文件
比如说是D
ABC这三个你都别动它
这是为什么呢
是我在思考
当它情形出问题的时候
我可以起码能复原对吧
因为我第一次做的时候
没有考虑到这个问题
他在改了我代码的时候
他复原不了了
我又要从头开始
一点点的拆层三部
重来一遍
这叫不同情形下的一个处理办法
也叫一个工作流
那么你在处理这种问题
像你在做测试代码
你的持仓
你的委托单
你的下单信号
你的下单方法
你获取行情等等
你把它全部拆开
比如有10个部分
你给它工作流
就是把10个部分
先分别写好
分别做一个简单测试
都没有问题
然后你来一个
最后的总工作流的时候
让它一步一步的合
两个加在一起测一次
三个加在一起测一次
等等
这样一次过来之后
就没问题了
波动情形是什么呢
当某一个处理
比如说1加1处理出问题的时候
AI该怎么办
你要告诉他
比如说是即
就是马上终止复原
是一种处理办法
对不对
第二是生成一个新的文件
把这两个代码合并到一起
并且来查一下
为什么跟原来两个原代码
是差异在哪
对吧
他这个是能做到的
因此这就是我说的
拆解问题和解决问题的办法
一定是你人在做的
至于怎么想到这些方法呢
那就是经验的积累了
这就是每个人
其实你不管是用AI
还是用手写
他会发现在每个时代
都有技术差
那这个技术差
一定要跟得上时代
对吧
所以大家要经常思考这个问题
这就拆解问题
给大家举两个例子
能更好地感受到这个
做监工的就是我刚刚说这个
你要第一时间指出他的错误
一定要第一时间指出
他不会认为自己错的
很少会认为自己错
因为在他的理念里面
不知道什么叫错
他没有一个概念叫错误
他只有一个概念是
我有没有把这段代码跑完
你的任务在他的脑子里
是否完成了
而不是你的脑子
所以说你一定要
及时地制止他的错误才可以
及时地纠错非常有必要
并且可能是需要你自己
进行一种侦探一样的去查线索
他可能哪里错
这也有一个具体的例子
像我还是回到刚刚那个项目
在当水军那一步
就在论坛发帖那一步
我发现有个问题
他怎么样都不能提交那个答案
就是我不是发布答案吗
但是呢他能贴上去
我也看到他贴上去了
他提交按钮死活按不了
那我就在查问题在哪里
让他查了快一小时吧查不出来
然后我就让他再执行一遍
我让他看
我发现他在输入字数的时候
上面写的已输入字数是零
然后我就去问他
我说这已输入次数是零
是为什么
然后他告诉我
可能是因为
他是直接拿这个后台去输入的
并没有点击这个输入框
所以说我只能看到输入的样子
但其实没有输入进去
才把这问题解决
但是如果你不能
第一时间判断出来
可能是这个原因
或者这里有异常
你和他聊一天
你们俩都聊不出来这个东西
这就是监工
你必须要高于他
你才能更效率的去做
哎呀这件事
这也是我刚开始强调的
你前面的基数到底有多少
决定你最后的成果
这个效率是多少
好吧
就这一步
我们接着往下看
这是我想给大家讲的
我们讲的那个
叫做我们做的东西
其实有专有名词
就我们人做的一件事
或者我说的一些
现在AI卖的一些软件
它叫agent
agent叫代理人
也叫智能体
它其实就叫人工智能体
它在做什么呢
这是AI之后
兴起的一个词汇
其实它就是
把问题具体化
细分化
并且翻译成
AI可能能理解的东西
来告诉它做什么
以及像我刚刚
给大家举的例子的里面
出了问题该怎么办
出了问题该怎么修复
工作流是什么样的
这就叫AI智能体
我们很多时候把DeepSeek
把GPT
把Cloud这种东西
对就像监工
这个朋友总结的非常好
就是监工
我们现在就是从干活的人
变成了监工了
其实还在干活
没有区别
那么我们经常说的像DeepSeek
像GPT
像Cloud
它其实就是一个智能体
和底层模型的结合
真正的AI是什么呢
真正的AI其实它们底层模型
就是它们的叫做DeepSeek R1
GPT O3
Cloud 4
这叫真正的底层
它是一些大数据集合
然后来帮你把问题输入出来
就是拿到东西之后
帮你分析的真正的大脑
那我们在说和听的这个过程
就像我们五官一样
就叫人工智能体
是把信息录入给它
输出给它
分析给它
因此我们人
到底这个人工智能体
能做到哪一步
取决于你最后能拿到的结果
到底好还是不好
就像是如果你的视力不太好
你的听力不太好
你一定不能给别人
一个满意的答案
对不对
但是你视力听力不好
怎么办呢
我可以戴眼镜
我可以有助听器
对吧
这就类比于
你在市面上买一些
比较优秀的AI智能体
那么你给它付费
比如说你像
我自己用的这个Cursor
或者说
字节新出的那个
叫做TRA的那个软件
大家都会付费
你看我一个月是给他20美金
那边也差不多100多块钱
我为什么要付这钱呢
就是为了买这些工具
让我听的跟
看的更清楚
更有效
这些就是AI智能体是什么
那么我们一直在
对付的这东西是什么呢
叫做幻觉
这次大家也可以拿到之后
跟别人去聊一聊
叫AI幻觉
AI幻觉是我们一直在
克服的一个东西
它源自于什么呢
源自于我们跟AI
是两个物种
我们是人
他们是机器人
我们可以这么说
然后我们的理解不一样
因此他理解的一些东西
跟我们理解的一些东西
不一样
因此AI就会出现一些幻觉
幻觉会有什么问题是
比如我那天跟他讲一个事
我说你这个错了
他说你说的对
我确实错了
我现在就更改
然后给了我一模一样的答案
然后我就问他
我说你都知道自己错了
为什么你还给我一模一样的答案
这明明是个错的答案
他一样会回复我
对不起我知道错了
我再去改一改
又是错的答案
然后他在给我答案之前
他会跟我说一句
这次一定没有问题了
我们已经完成了
哈喽四横可以听到吗
突然一下没声音
刚刚麦克风没声音了
现在好像没电了
不好意思
我接着说
有个小插曲
接着说
我们刚才聊到幻觉这个东西
我接着再聊
幻觉这个东西
其实就是我们的理解不一样导致的
所以说
你去针对它
给它讲一些事情
比如说你告诉它
你这个错在哪
而不是说一句你错了
就能有效地改善
AI幻觉这件事
也能有效地让它
不要再出类似的问题
这个来怎么解释呢
怎么来降低呢
就是我们把一些
专有的一些知识
一定要给它
而不是让它自己想
举个很简单的例子
我们来一个最简单的AI幻觉
都不用AI幻觉了
人的幻觉
大家都做期货的
我不知道你们有没有过
这个情况
我在天青群和一些
做期货的老手
都跟我问过这个问题
大家也可以自己想想
自己没过这个问题
正常锁
正常锁是三位
不是四位
开头是大写
经常有人
基本上隔一天都有一次
来问我
老师
我的合约为什么错了
明明是FG2609
为什么它错了
这其实就是一种幻觉
为什么是幻觉呢
是因为
你没有一个知识是
正常锁的合约
一定是大写加三位
再加上有些软件
它为了优化
它自认为的优化
它把它改成四位了
那么你在这两个信息
拼到一起的时候
你就会认为
政商所的合约
它就该是四位
大家能理解这个
换句话说从哪来的吧
就是你的信息偏差
其实我们跟人家
也是一个道理
那么怎么办呢
你告诉人家
政商所的合约是这样的
它在给你写代码的时候
也不会出错了
这是第一种
第二种
我一般会告诉他
或者给他一个文档
国内的期货合约
全品种
到底是什么样子的
他们的合约规则是什么
乘数是多少
单位是多少
我还会给他解释
最小单位和最小乘数
是什么意思
保证金的计算公式
我全部会给他
为什么
就是为了他
防止他自己有一个幻觉
他觉得这事应该是这么做
来给我做了
所以说AI幻觉克服的点
就是你能给他信息越多
他就越好
还有我举个例子
像是期权
股指期货跟股指期权
我不知道大家有没有做过
有一个非常让人容易误解的一个点
就是比如说上证50股指期货
对吧
我们就有一个上证50股指期货
然后客户用某个函数
我们有个函数是获取标的物的期权合约
他在做上证50的股指期权的时候
他一定或者说有很多人都会把
上证50的股指期货作为标的物写进去
因为他认为你上证50股指期货
你的期权不就是
的期权不就应该是上证50股指期货的期权吗
其实不是啊
他们俩的标的物是一个东西
都是上证50指数
所以说上证50股指期货跟上证50股指期权
他们是一个标的物
叫上证50股指
大家可以去中金所的官网看
中金所官网是介绍过这东西的
但是很多人会经验主义认为
上证50估值期权
它的标的5就是上证50估值期货
通过这两个例子
大家能理解了
AI幻觉说白了
就是跟我们有时候
平常犯的错是一样的
我们会想当然的认为
什么是对的
什么是正确的
什么是我们知道的
AI也是一样
它可能比我还要更明显
因为人会嘴硬的
AI不会
它是另外一种方式嘴硬
你像有时候我错了
我就会说对不起
我确实不太了解
AI不会说这个的
他跟你说的都是一些场面话
因此呢
想对付AI幻觉
其实你只能做到的是
不断地更新自己的知识
和问他你可以掌控的东西
比如说你问他期货策略
你问他期货的知识
只有你完全掌握了这些东西
你再问他
不然没有意义
因此为什么
有些人跟我说
说他是程序员
他什么会不会AI以后
代替他的工作了
可能性是有的
但是我觉得吧
这东西
两极分化
我只认为两极分化
是会更严重
并不会代替工作
因为会用的人更会用
不会用的人更不会用
效率大家会被这个陈述给拉开
这是我一个想法
那么具体怎么去做这个AI
和怎么去用呢
我来接下来就真正来讲方法了
前面是讲了一些
聊了一些认知上的东西
和一些我自己的一些经验
希望对大家有些帮助
我就很开心了
没有特别实质性的东西
就是希望大家更好的理解AI
好吧
那接下来就讲一些真正的方法
我来做是怎么去跟AI去优化它的
这个是最重要的规则
这是最重要最重要的规则
现在的AI
我们先不说网页版的AI
网页版的AI也有
网页版的AI
像我之前在跟豆包和DeepSick聊的时候
我会给他明确说
你给我答案是什么格式
你给我答案的范围是什么
你给我的答案一定要遵循
A B C D E
这叫规则
你在问他问题之前
给他这些条条框框
会让他的幻觉减少
会让他给你的回答更接近你要的东西
这叫规则
所以说规则对AI是很有用
也很有帮助
也是让大家能到另外一个台阶的一个东西
就是一定要有写规则这种理解
和写规则这种习惯
再去用VM
但写规则不是很简单的
就你不能给一个人说
你说你一定要做这事
但是人家问你说
问我为什么要这么做
你说我也不知道
你就得这么做
那这是不合理的
所以你一定要知道
为什么要求他这么做
就像我刚刚在一开始解答的
举的那个例子
我有三个部分合成
我会给他一条规则是
你在合成成功的时候
你一定要把几个东西
另外写一个Python文件
你在合成的过程中呢
你不要去擅自改两个部分的代码
只把拼接部分做一下
如果你拼接之后发现有问题
立即还原两个原代码
并且取消这次动作
我们再来看问题在哪
这个规则我给他的原因
就是因为我第一次失败了
我总结的原因
我没有给他这个规则
结果导致我本来可以运行的
三个分部分的代码
最后不能做了
所以我知道我为什么要要求他
我也知道我要给他什么样的规则
那么最后就成功了
对吧
因此这个立规矩没有那么简单
你一定要想明白
你立这条规则的前因后果是什么
或者你经历过什么失败
这是很重要的
有规矩以后
它就不太会自由发挥了
那我们用它呢
效率就高了
怎么立规矩呢
我等一会儿
跟大家说一下
最简单一个办法
我有一个建议
我不知道大家有没有写这个的习惯
我跟AI聊天之前
我一定会拿一个机式本
或者我用的是Notebook
无所谓
就是你拿一个
类似于机式本的东西
你就用回车
作为你的这个逻辑分界线
跟它去写清楚
我要的一个东西
ABCDE
这样子
写的完完整整的
把你想到的要求
全部写完
一次性复制给他
或者把这个附件
上传给他
这就是一种
立规矩最原始的阶段
刚刚有个朋友讲的
那个办法也不错
而且也很聪明
我后面也尝试过
这种办法
就是AI其实专精
和他们的一个优点
是不一样的
我后面也会讲这件事
就AI其实
它的一个特色不一样
比如刚刚提到几种AI
Cloud的这个AI
是写代码非常厉害
但是呢
像Chad GPT和DPC给他解析能力非常强
因此我会让GPT去先帮我解析问题
比如说我刚刚讲的那个
我需要写一个专业策略
我该分为几步
能让Cloud能理解
那GPT可以帮我拆解这个问题
我把GPT拆完之后
我会跟他说
好 你拆解的不错
你来给我生成一套规则的TXT文档
或者一般叫Markdown文档
因为Markdown的格式会好一些
他把文档生成给我
我再把这个文档
我再交给Cursor和他的底层
Cloud4这个东西去写
这就是一个完整的工作流
你可以用两个AI
来完成一件事情
所以刚才朋友讲的
没有问题
这也是能做的
就是方法很多
但是原理一定是这样
你一定要给你
最后工作那个东西
一个分析好的结果
那前面GPD做的什么
是帮我人解决了问题
那相当于我要给他钱
我一个月还要再多付20美金
所以我一个月的花费
变成40美金
就是变成了200多一个月了
就不是100多一个月了
如果还需要别的东西
我还有别的AI在用
我一个月AI上的花销
大概有80到100美金
因为我要三四种AI
结合到一起来使用
我才觉得
能到我要的效果
对吧
像Google又出了一个新的AI
我在搜东西的时候会用它
等等等等
当你了解每个AI的优点的时候
你就会发现
把它们结合到一起
工作效率非常高
这就是一个规矩的实现
也是工作流的一种实现
就是这样子的
然后第二个选项
我非常建议大家做
这是我跟一个国外的大佬学习的
他之前发过一个
AI使用的手册代币书
我去深啃了英文
我啃完了
发现他的最终的一个想法就是
你让AI尽可能给你参考选项
而不是直接给你答案
为什么
AI刚我有说过
它是一个做概率这种事的
那么你让它给你三个选项
因为每个方法
每个实现目标的方法
肯定不止一种
它给你三种方法以后
它会自己来自我核查
三种方法哪个好
那它又进行了一遍概率的筛选
那么你最后得到最后答案的
这种情况就会更高了
就会更容易得到这个答案了
因此我一般会让AI
给我说的是
如果我要去写一个持仓
这是天晴的文档
你给我两种写的方法
并且告诉我
每种方法好在哪
好他会给我讲好在哪
然后我再去稍微过一遍代码
我觉得OK这个确实好
然后呢如果我觉得这里有问题
我就说我觉得这里可能没有那么好
你是怎么得到结论好在哪
你去反问他
你去反问他的时候
他就会再去过一遍
他的AI的底层逻辑
可能会否认自己
可能会给你很坚定的说
哪里有问题
那么这种呢一般是逻辑性的AI
会更好用一些
像GPT啊像DbSeq啊
他们会很好的去自我反思
那么你反思完以后呢
最后把你的这套方案
最后决定的方案给Cloud
让Cloud给你写代码
这就是一套完整的流程
第三的是
等会儿科斯走的时候
大家可以看到
我现在都不会让他
直接给我写代码
我会让他先跑一遍
因为我在最开始用的时候
我是他给我一个代码
或者大家现在还在用
网页版的AI的时候
我觉得大家工作流程应该是
你生成一个代码
复制到你的电脑里
跑一下
有bug
把bug再复制回去
来回寻复
后来我发现
它效率太慢了
我感觉是我在给他打工
不是他在给我打工
因此我后面给他立了一条规矩
就是你在给我任何代码之前
先跑一遍
跑一遍之后
如果有很明显的代码错误
不能跑通
你先想办法解决
起码给我的答案是
能跑通的代码
这个很有意义
原因在哪里呢
比如说拿天晴的代码举例子
比如说是获取持仓
我们的函数叫get position
但是如果你直接问divsync
它会给你一个答案叫做
我觉得获取持仓就是get
我只是说夸张点
get持仓
它写的中文拼音
然后它就很自信地告诉你
代码没有问题了
你一跑你会发现
这个get持仓函数不存在
好处是什么呢
它发现不存在
他就会去查
发现这个函数确实不存在
这时候我再给他上传一份天晴的文档
他就会去天晴文档里面去查
该的负责性函数是什么
如果他不知道
他就会一直查
查到他能知道这个函数为止
你要做的工作量就少了很多很多很多了
所以说一定要让他自己先检测
再来给你答案
不要让他给你答案
你来检测
那你其实工作量没有降低多少的
好吧
这个呢
是我觉得更难的一个点
上面是个方法
下面一个是
开始的时候你需要做的一件事
也算是
我觉得是一个重心之一
很多人不知道自己需求是什么
这点不要说AI了
就是我认识一些代写老师
我跟他们有时候会聊天
也有吃过饭的
也有聊过的
我们这边有不少的客户呢
不会写天气
不会写代码
就跟我说
老师你帮我找个代写吧
我说行
我说比较贵
他说贵没事
帮我解决问题就行
后来那个代写老师呢
也很开心
说好又接个单子了
结果过一两天
俩人都跟我说黄了
我们再就是不行
我就有时候问为什么
说客户
比如说你在做一个
手工交易多少年了
你有个趋势策略
你觉得自己挣钱
事实你确实挣钱
挣了很多年
做得非常好
有个指标
非常厉害
这个确实我认识很多大佬
是很厉害
但是转成量化的时候就不行
为什么
因为你并不知道
很多时候
我们有一个东西叫盘感
但代码没有什么叫做代码感
它就是对或者不对
你翻译不出来自己盘感
你翻译不出来
自己的指标是什么
就是你翻译不出来
真正的那个规律是什么
有时候你可能
就是当时的你的状态很好
你的判断能力
非常快非常强
你也看过类似的东西
你看了无数次
你马上就能在手工作判断
但你电脑在你代码上
你总结你总结不出来的
对吧
所以说你想要的东西
你有时候你不能理解
你不能理解
AI更不能理解
它写不出来你要的东西
我们很多客户让人家给它写
双均线写这个写那个
最后来过来跟我说
老师这个信号
为什么跟我平常手工作的
完全不一样
是我代码出问题了
还是哪里出问题了
其实都没有出问题
只是因为从一开始那一步
大家就错了
你不能总结出来
你平常手工交易这么多年
成功的原因
你总结不出来
那代表也写不出来
这种情况我一般建议大家
接着做手工消息也不错
然后再慢慢地摸索
其实不要去纠结于
什么最新的这种科技
什么的并不是的
我觉得其实深度越深的人
成功的概率越大
这是第一点
第二点
你要知道自己如何达到
就像我刚刚有举的例子
我要他给我写个水军的东西
我是知道
我要你写个水军
可能会分为几个步骤
我会告诉你
我几个步骤的流程
我是需要怎么样的
比如说
我需要你先去豆包的网站
我给他说一个完整流程
你们可以体验一下
你需要去豆包的网站
点击豆包的对话框
输入给我几个答案
并且等待100秒
把答案拿到
拿到之后存到本地
然后把这个答案去
第二步就是你去登录论坛
输入账号密码
点开提问
等待10秒
因为等待那个网页刷新
再把这个问题复制进去
点击提交
等待100秒
这是完整的一个流程
你要知道这整条路径是怎么样的
策略也是一样
跟大家讲
你要做什么
你要先解决登录
登录完以后
获取你能订阅的所有东西
K线周期等等等等
全部都搞完
搞完之后开始来判断
信号是什么
开半价收半价
然后你再细一点
你要知道真要处理什么
第一处理以往的委托单
因为委托单它是有时间的
你触及不了的话
比如说你的一个条件是
当持仓不等于零的时候
那就出问题了
因为当你持仓不等于零的时候
可能委托单在交易所那边
你持仓也不等于零
对吧
所以你同时可能要处理委托单
你要处理成交单
你要等多少秒
包括你的追单
你的什么逻辑
或者可能会有个插针的行情
你要跟他说
当你的这个均线
遇到你最新的一根K线的收盘价
在上一根的涨幅
百分之多少的时候
停止你的策略
这些大家去聊
应该一下就能明白
这都是你们在做交易的时候
关心的事
但是你一定要总结的这么细给他
你才能写出一个策略来
你不能说在写的过程中
我知道这个东西怎么样
那是不可以的
你要提前知道这个东西
所以说你想要的东西是什么
这很难的
大家可以用思维导图这个方法
我喜欢用
我也推荐大家用
就是你用思维导图
它不是个分叉吗
跟树枝一样
你把它分到不能再细了
当你能做到这一步的时候
你把这东西给AI
就没有问题了
而且思维导出导出来
就是Markdown的格式
这是一种文件格式
叫Markdown
其实就是列表
小列表
小列表的小小列表
AI自动就可以用了
是这样的
所以大家一定要想这个东西
因此呢
我觉得逻辑能力
是我们最厉害的一个东西
所以说它能带领
我们的苦力活动
但是脑力活动和决策能力
还是对我们来
所以我觉得AI不能代替人类
大家应该也不用担心
也不用再担心
量化手工交易这块呢
我跟大家稍微聊聊
后面就不是特别
那个主线那个东西了
就是我个人觉得量化
这也是刚刚一直在贯穿那个点
我觉得量化
你如果想做量化
怎么来决定
我是不是适合做量化
就是看你到底
有没有一种模型的一种理念
什么意思
就是你不能说
今天我的心情好
或者今天下雨
今天天晴
我的持仓就在10%
就在15%
或者说我持仓
没有一个固定判断标准
我开仓品仓
也没有一个固定判断标准
这是不行的
量化交易呢
在我看来呢
它是利用一种数学模型
来做事情
你这数学模型
不管你是用因子
还是用比较简单的量化
其实说白了
就算是我们说的双均线
我们就拿这种
比较简单的例子
它不也是这种数学模型吗
就当A大于B的时候
我要做一个什么事
A小于B的时候
说白了
不就在做这件事情吗
因此呢
如果你不能这样子量化
量化是什么意思
就是稳定的
持续的
不变的
把某个条件
把你的想法
变成某个条件
变成某个不等式
某个等式
在做不到这一步之前
其实量化交易都不是特别适合进入的
都不是特别适合
因为你的这个观点会造成
你在走的过程中有很多的疑惑
就为什么他跟我一开始做的交易不对
为什么我不能把成功复制出来
原因在于第一步
那量化的优势是什么呢
这有些都是比较常见的
就是比如说无延迟
其实也有延迟
只不过他按的速度比你快一点
你按的够快也行
交易的准确性
因为不受人为情绪影响
但是这个东西呢
我之前跟一个朋友在聊
我一个客户问我
我每次开仓之后只赢
我总是忍不住
忍不住等等
怎么办
你量化没办法帮我解决
我说你也能关机
你量化有啥用呢
你不能解决自己这个问题
有啥用呢
其实它只是一定程度上
让你不受人为倾向的门槛变大了
但你如果真的还是一个
不能控制情绪的人
没有用
还是得修身养性
第一点
第二点就是回测这个东西
像我刚刚说的调餐
它确实能把一些重复的活
做得比不错
比如说像是它能迭代一些
我双均线有什么均线比较好
或者说在股票里面
你有1万只股票
我要去筛金差死差连续三天
我一个个看看不过来的
你即使去用招用软件
我也看不过来
那比如说我拿量化
其实量化大家不要去
局限于做交易
量化其实做一些分析也不错
我把1万只股票拿过来
我可以筛我的股票的大盘股
流动性大于多少的股票
我筛掉了7000只
只需要5分钟
就能筛掉7000只
还剩3000只
我去筛最近有金差死差的
筛掉2000只
大概有10分钟
2000只里面
最后1000只
我在筛连续进去死查几天的
又筛完只剩四五只
整个过程不到半小时
但是你们自己做股票
你要把大盘一万只筛完
你筛到第二天开盘都被你筛了出来
对吧
这就是量化
其实就这种理念
我想说的就是
大家不要局限于量化
一定要做交易
量化能做的事情很多很多
最后那个决策权
你也可以来做
就是他只给你提供信号
只是来给你辅助作用
最后是不是要交易
你也可以结合人工
没有问题的
好吧
这是我想给大家扩广点思路
量化能做的事情
不止就是一个完整的自动
怎么能做到一个无人盯
无人看守的全自动盯盘
其实我在跟他的一个答案
就是我不知道你们答案是什么
我觉得在你问我这个问题的时候
我觉得你不如去花几千块钱
雇一个看盘的人
这事更好解决
对吧
你要解决的问题
就是有人帮你临时处理
那你为什么不花点钱
你去找个人呢
为什么我会这么想
因为你要去写一个
无人看守的程序
首先你得在那盯着他
看一个月
他是不是出bug
那跟你自己盯着有什么关系呢
而且bug有时候是偶发性的
你看他看一个月都没事
第二个月就有事了
你要从头写
不要从头干
对吧
所以说很多时候
大家要考虑一个性价比的问题
到底什么东西适合你
这个是非常关键的
那量化交易的解决方案呢
这个大家也都知道
我只想说大家选择
适合自己就好了
虽然说我是天晴的人
就是但是我一直跟你说
我不喜欢太多广告
因为他那边
大家是他的粉丝跟观众
对吧
我觉得这做广告也不好
第二呢
是我觉得每个人
要选择适合自己的
第一种呢
是那种软件端的量化
你像卖语言啊
像是TB啊这种
其实你入门
还有还有通达性
你入门不用特别的那个讲究
比较讲究吧
你入门不需要特别的自由
你只需要他帮你写些自定义指标
或者说稍微的一些自动化
我觉得就够了
你没有必要去学Python语言
学C++语言
没有必要
对吧
你用不到
如果呢你想学
你觉得你需要再进一步全自动开发
你有这个经历
有这个能力
或者说你有这个需求
你再去学
比如说Python
那就用天井
对吧
开源的Python量化
如果你觉得还进一步
你课班出身
你或者你的计算机非常强
你学习能力非常强
你要直连
你要托管
那CDP有个免费的方案
就CDP API
你直接免费就可以用了
你也可以选择它
对吧
也不要钱
因此就是你选择
适合自己的是最重要的
而不是说
我一定要某个产品
最忌讳是什么
我旁边有个人
拿什么产品发财了
他来跟我说
我拿这个东西
今天比如拿天晴
我拿天晴去年挣了100万
然后你就把
用天晴和挣100万
连到一起了
不是这样的
他可以100万的时候
也不会来找你说
对不对
因此选工具一定要选自己适合的
那么快捷专业版这东西呢
就是一个PC软件
就是天行是这样的
大家简单看一下
其实它就是一个Python的一个开源软件
然后它的跟AI适配的原因
是因为等下我演示一下
因为你很容易把
你的库就是我们的库
就是我们的整个的说明文档传给AI
AI可以先学一遍
再来回答你问题
这是没有问题的
所以说Python的这个解决库呢
也是我们一开始走的一条最难的路
我们没有给大家去装任何的软件
只是一个安装包
安装包难度是哪里
安装包难度
就是你可能装都装不上
我们有一半的客户吧
是被挡在安装这一步的
装不上
他问我说
李老师你帮我远程装一下吧
我是不装的
我一般跟他说
如果我远程帮你装
我觉得没有任何意义
就像你电脑都不会开机
你跟我说
老师你帮我开了机
我就会在电脑上做交易了
不可能的
你也不知道鼠标键盘怎么用
所以说有利有弊
当你会用之后
你会发现非常好用
原因是AI是能读取
它所有的信息的
给你的答案
AI换取就会少很多
免费是完全免费的
除了你要下载数据
下载数据要收钱
当然不要钱
专业版是一个PC软件
现在有不少新公司也免费了
它主要干嘛
它主要是
对你有多账户的需求的
多账户你比如说你有
五六个账号吧
五六个账号
或者说五六个新公司的账户
这种情况下
你可以用快捷专业版
预警和风控做的不错
然后各种指标算法都有
交易这一块和监控这一块
都是以多账户级别来思考的
所以说你有多账户的需求
快捷专业版还是不错的
推荐用
如果你没有多账户的需求
用快捷二三其实也蛮不错的
已经能满足需求
这个讲的这一块就在这边了
我这边先暂停个几分钟
大家可以看一下
该操码的该加Uni老师
或者加群的大家可以做一下
我刚好喝口水
然后给大家看一下
实操里面今天我做的那个事
以及整个界面
大家是要怎么做对吧
我稍微喝口水给大家说一下
大家都该直接结完了
等会最后也可以大家调到这
然后我来给大家讲一下
第二部分
这个就是Cursor
这就是Curso
我今天在用的东西
我把历史的连接录拿出来
调到最开始
给大家看一下
其实也是没那么好用
不是一开始就好用的
这是我跟他的对话
我首先给他一个场景
就是我想学下继续学习
然后继续学习我这个库
就是我这个环境
大家可以看到这个部分
我这个环境需要安装什么东西
对吧
好
那我就跟他说
我有这个库
我不想装
你帮我
我这台机子已经装好拍上了
你来帮我做
他的答案就是什么
你可以看
他说
他先检查一下
然后他看到我有一个环境配置文档
这个其实我没有传给他
他自己能看得到
现在AI的智能体
这个东西我跟他聊天了
就是右半部分
就叫AI智能体
他在帮我拆解问题
他拆解的还不错
这就叫AI智能体
那他拆解完以后呢
他读了一下这个环境对吧
读了之后他跟我说
他来帮我安装
其实你可以看
他有写了一个
我让他去给我展示他要做什么
我需要一步一步的知道他要做什么
因此他写了六步
他会先检查Python
再检查这个requirement
我刚刚这个要求是要装什么
然后创建康大环境
为什么他会到康大环境呢
因为他发现我这个对吧
都是康大created
就是说我是用这个
叫做康大的一个东西来控制的
所以他要去看一下康大对不对
然后创建环境
安装脚本
创建Jupiter
为什么呢
因为后面我有一个东西
是要安装Jupiter的
所以说他在这边又看了
更新一下这个文档等等等等
他就做了这件事
他会告诉我
因为这是我要求他
就是你们回忆一下
这就叫rules
我要求他一定要告诉我
他在做什么
而且告诉我做到哪一步
好
他就来了
第一步
然后我就终止了
你知道我就终止他了
我说你不要那么麻烦
这就是我跟你说
你要及时制止他
不要让他来帮你想当然那么多
我说我不喜欢这个康达
因为我不想让他帮我控制版本
你帮我就简单安装就行了
你也啥也不用干
对吧
他说那只要这样就行
他说他知道了
然后
他就来说创建一个脚本
然后呢
他就会告诉我已经做了什么
每一步在做什么
大家可以展开看
这他那个思考过程
他就会展示给我
对吧
展示给我
然后你可以看到一个点
就很有意思的
就是我刚刚讲的
AI幻觉或者人和他的理解
是不一样的
大家注意我这边是明确说了
我不需要康达
大家不用知道康达什么东西
反正我就说
我明确不需要这个东西
然后你发现
他在写的里面
这一行是什么
创建康达环境
大家现在能理解我
这已经算是比较好的AI了
大家不要觉得是比较闹的AI
这已经是比较好的
而且还蛮贵的那种了
他完全是无视
我刚刚给他说的话
按照自己的思路
又去创建康达环境了
然后他告诉我
他已经OK了
他做得很好
我该怎么做
我的使用方法是什么
然后用使用这个康达
看到没
我已经明确告诉他
不要用的时候他用了
那么我就说运行和解码上有问题
我就双击实施
实施不了
我就接着问他问题
这就是我说的
就是你一定要在这个环境下
你来实现和运行
告诉他问题是什么
他又会去解决
比如说修复
添加检查
手动执行等等
对吧
然后他还会给我总结
但总结的很可惜又是错的
就是这就是你要一眼看出
这是我们要做的活
他说的任何话你都别信
先怀疑再去看
这是我给大家说的
就这么一个情况
其实到这里完全解决不了任何问题的
完全解决不了任何问题的
然后我发现呢
他就是在已经
耳机经常会断
不好意思
他在自己的循环里面就会
他已经走不出去了
就在这里已经走不出去了
那我会在做什么呢
我会说
你先别急
你也别装东西了
你先帮我把Python的路径
就是说把这个环境
你先检查一下
你不要去搞这些东西了
就是你可以事实地
制止他现在做的事情
并且告诉他
下一步该怎么做
这个我给大家举的
只是环境配置这么个点
大家可以去举一反三
去想你在写代码的时候
你在写策略的时候
如果你不能现在认为
或者你判断不出来
他已经走不出来了
你现在就不适合再用他了
因为他就会在这跟你纠结
一天里面
纠结不出来任何东西
现在他来检查的时候
就会告诉他要做什么
又在检查康大环境
看到没
他又在检查康乃环境
就是他很拧的
就是AI其实说很拧的
比你想象的拧多了
当你给他一个Rules
让他给你完全展示
他接下来要做什么的时候
你才能看得到他拧在哪
这是我给他定下来规则以后
我才能很明确
或者我能很快地知道
他哪里出问题了
因为他告诉我了
但大家正常用的情况下
很可惜他不会告诉你的
他只会给你一个答案
他告诉你不对
或告诉你一个假消息
已经OK了
明白了
这就是Rules的一个重要性
然后这边我就跳过了
反正就是康乃也不行
什么也不行
对吧
乱七八糟都不行
然后发现
他就告诉我一个错误的答案
叫做Python未正确安装
这就是AI幻觉
他幻觉的意味
他的错误是Python没安装
其实是吗
不是
是因为我不让他用Canda
我Canda没有安装
他这边用了一堆指令去找Python
其实最后什么都没找到
那这种怎么办呢
他给我的解决方法
有用吗
可能有用
对吧
但不是我要的东西
那不是我要的东西
我已经装过Python了
那怎么办呢
我给他的第二条路走
这时候你作为一个监工
你一定要知道
有什么代替方法
就像你底下的人干活
你不能说他跟你说
老板我干错了
你就把他开了
没有这么干活了
你会跟他说
你可以试试这个方法
你再去试试
那我做了一个什么办法
我跟他明确地讲了
忘记conda和环境配置
你参考我另外一个工作区域
因为我在这个Python文件
这个文件夹里面
我已经配置好了
所以我告诉他
是你把这个conda
什么都忘了
你可以去学前辈
对不对
就像是你底下人
干活干不好
你说我们之前
有个成功案例
你去学一下
我又换了一个思路
再跟他聊
好
他现在就去检查了
去检查这个环境是什么
他就检查这个分区的配置是什么
检查Python环境
不拉不拉的
检查完才来复制到现在这个地方
让他一步步查
一步步查
你看到没
这边他查出来了
Python版本也有了
这里就已经有Python版本了
他也查出来问题是什么了
看到没
他已经这边就成功了
他找到了
刚才说找不到
为什么就能找到了呢
因为我给他的一个正确的方法
他找到了
所以说你有时候你要制止他
去换一条完全不同的路
那这个东西就是我们人的价值
我们得要能想到这一点
对吧
它并不是一个技术门槛
大家可以看到
我没有打过任何一句代码
这是一个非常白话的一种思路
就是我之前成功过一次
你现在失败了怎么办
你要不学一学
之前成功的那个例子呗
对不对
就是这么一个道理
其实很白话的
那他成功以后
他就来帮我配置相同的
对吧
配置完
然后一步一步一步
就配置好了
然后配置环境成功了
他给我推荐这东西
你就不用看它了
然后配置总结
也总结完了
对吧
然后呢
我就跟他说
这里有个很有意思的地方
就是很有意思的一个点
他在这里跟我说
现在可以安装所有的包了
需要我帮你运行安装脚本吗
这里是我的一个问题
就是我也跟大家讲的
大家的语言是不通的
就是我不知道大家是怎么想
一般如果你跟我来讲
要不要我帮你去做一个什么事
我一般会说谢谢
我觉得一般是默认
就是你帮我对吧
一般是默认你帮我
结果这里我说了句谢谢呢
他跟我说不客气
然后他就停下来了
他没有帮我
这个就是
你一定要说一些
不要默认两可的语言
因为我感觉
这东西是很自然的
就是比如说别人跟我说
要不要帮你一下
李先生
我说谢谢
那就是让他来帮我
但是其实计算机
不会这么惯着你
他就是你跟他说谢谢
他真就觉得你谢谢
不需要他帮忙了
所以后来我就加了一句
帮我安装下
他才帮我装
这机器学习的各种东西
乱七八糟的装好了
装好以后
我干了个什么事
我这跳过了
这都才帮我装的过程
然后装完以后
我就跟他讲
我说我要去学习
我要跟Yoni老师
去请教过两天
对吧
我说你能不能帮我
生成一个或多个文件
我想看看你生成的东西
对不对
这就是代码了
大家可以看
这是加一起有1000多行
还有其他代码
应该有一两千行
他花了大概
十分钟不到就做完了
他写了五个测试
五个测试
我可以五个测试都跑
然后就把五个测试都做完了
他自己也告诉我
不知道哪一步了
然后他就可以运行了
然后我就告诉他
他就说你可以运行
所有的测试
就知道情况如何了
到这为止
我没有跟他写过任何代码
然后这里我给大家说一下
我没有去测试
这是我跟大家讲的另外一步
不要自己去运行
让他来给你运行
我说你帮我一个个测试
我只需要知道是否能正常运行
他在测试到第三个文件的时候
出bug了
这就是bug
出了一个bug
就是有一个参数不对
好处就来了
大家现在能切实感受到
好处在哪里
就是演示
这是他的话
这不是我的话
他得到bug以后
会立马停止演示
并且来跟我说
有一个错误
让我修复一下
他把它错误就修复了
修复完以后重新测试
没有问题了
然后全部都跑通了
给我一个工作的总结
全部正常
这就是
跟应该的一个完整测试
我直接给你看看
他给我写的东西怎么样
就是
比如说写了一个这个玩意儿
没有NonePy
他又是少了一个东西
叫NonePy的一个环境
对吧
那上午有的问题
上午能跑了呢
下午又必定能跑了
就这种东西吧
你完全就不知道
什么时候能跑
什么不能跑
怎么办呢
像这种情况
你看没有NonePy
这个情况是为什么呢
就是因为
现在这个环境又变了
现在这个环境可能又变了
又变了以后呢
我现在这个环境里面
就没有囊派这个库了
对吧
那我可能就可以跟他说
我说下午运行是没问题的
为什么现在我运行
说没有囊派库
你现在又可以跟他说了
下午运行是正常的
对吧
你还可以说检查
一下之前的聊天记录
看看区别是什么
环境我没有动
你要把情音后给他讲明白
环境我没动过
区别是什么
你怎么帮我解决这个问题
你再去问他
他再慢慢帮你看
就是这么一个情况
那大概率呢
就可能这个库
跟我之前那个库又不一样
或者说我的环境又不一样了
环境是个很难的问题
你看现在就是
让我检查一下
这就是这个cursel的一个好处
他不会直接给我代码什么
他会给我一些命令
我可以选择执行不执行
假如我选择执行
他就来检查了
检查这个Python的版本是怎么样了
等等等等
就开始慢慢来检查这个东西
是不是对
来检查Python在哪里
对吧
他就一步一步
都是他给我的指令
他觉得接下来要做什么
接下来要查什么
等等等等
这全是他来做的
他一步步觉得
该做什么
这就是我说的AI智能体
你付费付的是什么
负责是他来帮你拆问题
拆解到比较细
他告诉你接下来这一步
可能要做什么来检查
什么事情
这是他的一个优点
在这个位置
但是很可惜
他不能百分百解决问题
因为我们要做一个好的监工
我们得好好看
他是不是真能解决这个问题
对吧
这就是这么一个情况
所以说那到底这个东西
他为什么出错呢
或者怎么样呢
不清楚
只有他来检查
为什么下午能用
现在不能用呢
也不清楚
只能他来检查完之后来告诉我
这就是这么一个情况
就这么一个情况
就可能他后面又做了一件什么事
或者你去跑另外一个代码的时候
出了一个什么事
他把环境给你改了
你完全就不清楚是
什么情况下会出这种问题
所以说很多问题在现实中
你会遇到很多
你可能马上能跑得好的
下面又不能跑好了
这都是很正常的一些事情
你只能跟他慢慢去聊
慢慢去解决
没有别的更好的办法
好吧
就是差不多分享就到这边了
刚好他还给个错
我还能去接着讲讲
就遇到错的时候怎么办
对吧
那就是这就是整个今天的一个分享
大家可以有什么问题
可以去提问或者怎么样
我觉得还是比较实际的一个分享
今天这个大家可以去有什么问题
可以来跟我说好吧
OK非常感谢慈恒老师
就真的是讲的讲的很多
也讲的很深
那我其实有一个问题
就是像很多其实量化
就是刚接触量化的小伙伴们
他可能刚接触到
比如说咱们AI加天晴的时候
他不知道从何下手
比如说用AI基于咱们天晴
开发一个简单的均线策略
为例子
就是那森老师
你的建议的步骤是什么
是先用AI写框架
再人工调整
还是说咱们先人工拆解需求
再让AI分布完成
我觉得这个东西
就像建房子一样
其实你在想建房子
第一步是做什么
第一步一定是
买砖买瓦
或水泥
那么其实第一步
都没有到那些
第一步是
首先你先检查一下自己
假如拿天晴举例
你Python技术如何
起码要学会的是一些基础
AI是可以帮你省掉
后面的学习步骤的
但是你基础一定要会
你要懂Python大概是什么
第一步
第二步你要懂天晴大概是什么
基础是非常重要的
就是天晴的文档
Python的基础
先学会以后
起码得学个皮毛
再来把AI拿过来
来用是比较好的
框架这东西是应该
你来用Python量化之前
或者说用量化交易之前
就应该自己有个大概的
因为手工交易
或者有一个交易的一套
完整的系统
其实应该是在这之前
你应该要完成的一件事
可能过来会更简单一些
这样的运行
OK了解了解
那其实
我看我们刚有个小伙伴
问的问题
他说
是的免费的AI
是能解决大部分
这个朋友说的没有错
就是为什么
就是我会付费呢
其实我这边没有完全展示
就是因为这只是一个
很简单的例子
我完全付费的原因是什么
我也可以跟大家讲一下
就是付费不付费
其实很多时候
是看你自己的一个需求的
我为什么要付费呢
这是非常简单的一些
Python文件
我是不需要付费的
你像你说的很多免费的
都是可以用的
但是我真正的工作流程
我是要写一个项目的
就是我是要写的是
几十个或者说上百个
Python文件
不是这种简单的
几个Python文件
所以我一定需要这一种
项目制的AI
能处理的一些东西
我解答一下你的问题
如果你不需要用项目制
这种东西的时候
没区别的
你讲这些功能
其实就像你说的
完全普通AI是能代替的
就是一定要知道
自己付费的需求是什么
我是知道自己明确的需求
以及它能帮我解决的东西
包括他上下文的管理
他项目之间的管理
和工作区域的管理
还有圆码的管理
我才会用它
是这样的
这个我也去解答一下问题
就是为什么我会付钱
和我不会建议
大家都付钱的一个原因
就是有问题
我也会解答一下
没事大家有什么问题
可以问
OK好的
森老师你看一下
评论区还有问题
MCP你说的什么
能说一下吗
这个我还真不太了解
你说这个缩写
它具体是什么意思
可以给我讲一下吗
OK
那我其实有一个问题
斯腾老师是这样子
就是大家都知道
像咱们信义科技
目前是支持140多家企业公司
那服务也是超百万的用户了
像您这边应该接触过
不同类型的交易
就是量化交易者
就是像您这边观察到
像新手和资深从业者在使用
比如说AI加量化工具的时候
他们最主要的差距是什么
就是包括新手
最常见的坑有哪些
以及大家还是要整体如何规避一下
智能体的结合
CDP是吧
CDP你理解为不能吧
天晴主要还是中继为主
还是中继为主
接入智能体这块的接口很简单
就是Python环境
你像我这个就是一个Python的编辑器
你都不用怎么接入
你在这边天晴是安装完以后
你可以直接把源码给他的
天晴源码你可以直接给他的
就是你像这种源码
你可以直接传给他
这环境我会把它调一下
你这种源码像TKPI
TKSDK的本地
你直接跟这个AI说一声
让他学就行了
这就叫结合了
其实都不用你们想的那么复杂
还有我们有网页版的这个文档
你把这个网址复制给他
就能做一个自己的这个document
就能做一个这个他的参考资料了
这就是一个开源
还有那个叫什么
没有框架的一个好处
然后我接着回答
Yuni老师那个问题
新手跟老手的区别
一个就是我今天这节课
就是努力想表达的认知上的问题
新手会觉得AI是一件
能帮我解决所有问题的一个事
这是新手的一个想法
但是像一些专业的机构
我之前有了解过
像一些专业机构
它去开发因子库什么的
也会用到AI
写代码像我们公司写代码
有时候也用AI
都会用的
但我们只会用它其中一部分
就是代替我们的人工成本
而不是代替规划项目
因子该怎么筛选
就我拿因子来举例子
正规机构是
它是已经有自己摸索了这么多年的
因子最难的其实不是因子挖掘
是因子的一个评分分析系统
我因子什么叫好什么叫坏
它已经有这么一套东西了
在此基础上
它有一个AI生成因子以后
到评选到落选
或者选中的一个标准
完整的工作流是有的
那么AI来帮它的事
只是以前人在无数的生成因子
现在是AI在无数的生成因子
但是生成的标准
拿到的标准
用不用的标准
是原本有的
这是机构
我觉得它比较强的地方在这
也强的有道理
因为人家花了那么多钱
像我们认识一些比较大的机构
他们也是每年投入硬件软件
上百万上千万来做的事
但也不用觉得特别焦虑
因为他们做的量大
我们做的量也没有那么大
就没有必要
要这么几百上万个因子
我们其实只需要
做自己想的一个东西
对 这个朋友讲的很对
他还帮我总结了已经
就是逻辑是最重要的
其实说到说一千到一万
你拿AI写代码
你请个人
花个几千上万的写个代码
自己从头学写代码
说白了都是写代码
但难得那个
不是你的思想代替不了的
因此就是这么个区别
就是新手我觉得
不要纠结于写代码
也不要盲目的容颜
先把自己那个逻辑
想明白
其他都好吧
OK了解了解
因为我也是希望
因为现在
因为我在B站上
是很多小伙伴
也都是对电话感兴趣
正准备入门
所以我觉得像AI
因为工具确实很方便
尤其是现在的
就是我们大家所常知的
这些AI
都是属于生产式的AI
它确实会出现很多
就是它虽然带来方便的同时
其实它更多的
会给咱们设置
很多的幻觉陷阱
所以我也是希望
大家能够提前避避坑
主要是这个样子
是的
这些陷阱像这种幻觉
像我刚刚给他演示一个
完整的我说的这些东西
其实我比较快速的
能知道这个问题
也是因为我天天在用
我经常在用的时候
我还在
我也看了不少论文之类的
还有各种文章的分享之类的
看看别人的经验
其实它也是个学习的过程
只不过你本来你觉得
你在学代码学什么
现在你在学AI
你还是在学
而且要学的东西
其实更多了
更多了
是这样的
对 是的 是的
我们这个小伙伴
总结的非常到位
来 大家看一下
其他小伙伴
如果有问题的话
我们的这个就是评论的地方
然后都可以大家敞开来聊一聊
因为孙子老师平时也很难得
能够邀请过来给咱们做分享
所以说大家就是把握住机会
包括其他小伙伴有
就是说比如说对于咱们天晴
有什么就是想在使用方面
有什么疑问也都可以
今天刚好孙子老师在这边
都可以直接问好吗
好的那我想问一下
你说
可以听见吗
可以的
你说吧
孙老师
那个就是我在那个
就是骗钱那个群里面
就是我在群里面提问题
我看孙老师之前
也专门给我解答过
其实刚才孙老师
分享这个
就是早期的
其实我们做开发
都是这个
参照官方的文档
比如有些问题
要去调试
提bug
其实这个难度比较大
我看现在
比如这个AI之后
相当于发射辅助
我们去做
我这边主要想问一下
就是比如我在做
那个实际量化应用的时候
比如我们要根据你每个品种
它的实际的最新的保证金
让我们要决定开多少手
还有你账户的情况
我现在就你们天琴
比如查账户每个品种的保证金
这个权限大概多久可以开通一下
这个我想了解
这个确实做不了
短期内也没法做这件事
这个代替方案
我以前在群里也讲过
其实这个东西保证金这件事
有很多客户有提过
它的难点在哪里
因为我们现在天琴是中继模式
中继模式
它是不能像直连一样
去查保证金率的
你的保证金率
是我们没办法直接拿到的
这是第一个问题
第二个问题是直连
我们不支持直连
所以就尴尬在这
之前我在群里提的解决方案
是你找客户经理
一般都会有
要一个保证金率的Excel表
它能变相的解决的点
是在哪里
就是因为这个东西
不会一般不会变
那么大概率你维持一个表
是没问题的
就是能解决你大部分的问题
而且做量化的大部分
是不会持仓满到
就是90多
或者你除非做一些特殊品种
一般不会这么做
所以说现在可能的解决方案
还是只有这个
是个不好意思
确实这个短期内
或者说暂时的开发计划
是不太容易做得到的
好 那谢谢孙老师
对 是的
大家有什么问题
也都可以直接再问
因为时间也比较晚了
而且今天也是周五
我可以提个问题吗
您说您说
刚才听到您的
其实就是讲的过程中
提到一个
就是自动交易的问题
您的建议就是过一个人可能会比使用一些自动交易系统可能更可靠一些
这点我有观点的话我听得不是很清楚
能不能再讲一讲
您能再说一下吗
刚才有点模糊的一个声音
您刚才在讲过的东西提到过
如果自己做一个交易系统
自动交易系统
我过一个人来说
您可能觉得过一个人可能会比自动交易系统更稳定
就少一些bug
那块逻辑我听得不是很清楚
因为您这边不是有个量化插发的吗
量化插发的东西不就是人算法和电脑吗
这个东西如果不出现自动交易法
半自动交易法的形式的话
其实是打造到那种
自动交易的逻辑的本质吧
我了解了解
了解你说的是什么
这个是这样的
这个是咱们可以就也都聊
大家每个人对量化的想法不一样
我刚刚分享的是
我对量化的理解是
量化的做法其实并不在乎
我是人在做还是机器在做
量化的做法是
只要是我有一套固定的规则和逻辑
我就能把它叫做量化
举个例子
就是我拿各种软件做云条简单
你每天比如说你拿一个Cell表
每天给他上传一个
下载一个
一天不看他
就云条链在那边指引止损
或者开仓品仓
那您说这算不算量化呢
其实有时候也算量化
对吧
我觉得量化
其实是一种规则性的东西
它跟手工不同的是
它的规则性更强
是不可改变的
就是你写好指标
写好信号
你不像是我在盘中看盘
我看这个上穿下穿
但是我又看到旁边
有个小山峰小山谷
我这次上穿
我就决定不做交易了
是不是我临时起信的
但量化不是
量化是你不管旁边有什么
你设定好这个条件
他就要做
因此是不是半自动
其实原因在哪里呢
是因为很多人
他到全自动这一步
他的性价比太低了
可能我刚刚描述的不是很准确
你这么来想法
你的这个想法和你的一个意愿
是我们所有人都想做的
它是一个自动印钞机
这大家都期望的一件事
但是有些东西的性价比
它值不值得你去做
其实这就是一个
你需要思考的一个问题了
我举个例子
你的代码跑得非常好
交易跑得非常好
但是你就是担心
它可能出问题
但你也不知道
怎么解决它出问题
你可能要花十几天
二十几天去解决这个问题
但是你其实是有时间
去盯着一下它的
那这种情况下
为什么不起源用后转呢
对不对
我想表达这个意思
就是你可能会有性价比更高
以及更符合你现状的办法
就不要太死板的去用
大众人为的
就是一定要完全的自动化
这是我想表达的一个点
我可以这样整理一下
就您的观点
就是说
第一个您认为
可能做量化这件事情
它本身在于它的运作逻辑
就是完全由算法
其实还是人家算法
或者是其他的东西
其实是比较重要的关系 没有逻辑
这是第一点
第二个就是连接的性价比
可能是绝对没选择没有方式的一个必发性领袖
是的
其实您说的状况
其实就是我现在要做的事情
我斗体员大概有一个稳定的变化系统
但是最近刚刚接入了升级
所以想把它电梯自动化
所以很多东西在测试里面
所以很纠结的问题
这个我觉得你的思路可以变成
黑猫白猫抓到耗子觉得好猫
就不要一次想把它做完
先能跑 对吧
能跑之后再开始慢慢优化
其实软件讲究的是一个迭代
我们叫做敏捷开发
什么意思就是先能跑
跑完之后再慢慢再把旁边的东西给装起来
我觉得没有问题了
谢谢聊天
OK
看看小伙伴们
小伙伴们还没有其他的问题
对
如果没问题的话
那咱们今天时间也比较长了
快一个半小时了
然后咱们就到这里结束
好不好
看大家还有没有什么问题
如果没问题的话
那我们就结束了
我看一下屏
好像刚刚有人提问题
OK好的
非常感谢我们思腾老师的硬核分享
讲得非常的多
也非常的细
那希望今天这场分享
能够给小伙伴们带来更多的灵感
那后续呢
大家有到任何时操上的问题
也都可以关注咱们天晴的
那个就是B站的官方账号
叫心意科技
都可以去直接对接到咱们官方来做解答
那记得后续
持续多关注一下咱们天晴量化
以及Uni
那后面呢
还会有更多的电话干货上的分享给大家
那今天晚上的直播就先到这里了
好吗
非常感谢大家
感谢思恒老师
那最后祝大家交易顺利
咱们下次再会
好吗
好的再见
感谢你老师
感谢大家
拜拜